christina radish with kaleidor hi how
are you
hi good how are you i am very well
excellent work on this i was thoroughly
impressed with everything you did and
completely like i just could not stop
watching the story so thank you
thank you for saying that i appreciate
it
when we've spoken in the past you've
told me that even when the stories
you're telling are dark and the
characters are tortured you actually
have fun so what did you most enjoy
about this experience what what was the
most satisfying aspect of taking all of
this on
i think the most satisfying aspect of
this particular show because i you're
right i do always enjoy that part of it
was working with these uh actors and
the
the two directors as well michelle
mclaren and dana reed because there were
this the three of us directing the show
we were very collaborative we were very
closely linked we had to work together a
lot on the episodes because
something that one director would do
would affect what i was doing four
episodes later and so there was a lot of
back channeling a lot of conversation
between us of like
how we were going to construct the show
as a whole and so that was really fun
and then
the actors not only getting to act with
them but getting to direct them
wagner pippa you know chris choc like um
[Music]
just jamie obviously oh my god who's
like so incredibly talented so getting
to work with them
was probably the most rewarding thing
and i think each of them turns in one of
the best performances they've ever done
in this show
and they all kind of do something
different that they've never really done
before so it was really fascinating to
see them explore that and challenge
themselves
you've also said that you always try to
pull from your own life when you play a
character even if you don't have a
direct parallel to draw from so what was
it that first connected you to kirby
what was that first thing that you found
yourself connecting to and how did that
help you build the character out from
there well that was actually the hard
thing about this one because there
wasn't really anything i could pull from
of my own life i have not had
experienced or or
or know anyone who has experienced their
whole world changing all the time you
know somebody who's experienced trauma
i've played but i've never had that so
that was a new kind of challenge for me
that i really
really liked was
how do i play somebody whose world is
shifting around them and they are kind
of used to it they know
what's happening but they don't know why
and
there was no reference point for that
there was no
i couldn't go talk to anybody about that
i was nothing in my own life that i
could i could equate that with you know
so that was a kind of what i liked about
this was actually the fact that i
couldn't do that i you know i had to
really invent it every time the present
shifts for your character her hair
changes sometimes in small ways and
sometimes in major ways so how did you
approach what changes
you wanted to make to the character
every time her world shifted
yeah that was a tricky one because you
know
we wanted to make sure things were
believable we needed to make sure that
things were
um
choices that the character would make so
they couldn't be like oh all of a sudden
i had like crazy spiky hair or something
like that it had to be like within the
world of the character and it had to be
grounded as well
um and then but we also were trying to
find ways in the costume that that maybe
she changed so it wasn't just the hair
ways and the makeup that she changed so
it wasn't you know the hair is sort of
the most noticeable thing it's the first
thing you see but that we were also
trying to make sure it wasn't just the
hair that would change um so it was it
was it was definitely something that
i've never done before i've never had
you know i think i have like five
different looks in this show
um it was a definitely a certain point
why we reached the end of the show when
i had my last look that we were like
we're done right like there's no i
remember talking to silke the show
runner and being like there's no other
no others right because i'm out of ideas
of what i can do with my hair like
there's no there's no other shifts right
she was like that's it we're done
there's no other things
i think i thought it was so brilliant
because it does give you a sense that
okay things are a little different again
without you having to explain it every
time yeah exactly and it was a very
easily like easily um recognizable thing
too for the audience
you have also now directed episodes of
handmaid's tale which was more difficult
to direct episodes of that to direct
this and did one experience influence
the other at all definitely shining
girls because it's much it's a it's it's
a new show so you're setting up a new
show you're establishing something new
you're establishing a new story you're
establishing characters first seasons
are always that you know first seasons
are the hardest ones because you're
really you're setting up a world you're
doing this this world building so
um you're asking all these questions for
the first time you know by the time you
get to season four and five of a show
it's
it's a living breathing thing um so
definitely shining girls um
but i also
had so much like i said support from
michelle and dana the other directors i
didn't i never felt like i was alone in
in
in directing this show it felt like it
was
a very very collaborative experience and
the three of us felt like we were
working together on all of the episodes
in a way
i don't think it's too spoilery to say
that by the end of these episodes kirby
is able to
fill in some of the gaps and holes in
her life and have a bit of a better
grasp on what reality is
is the ending that we see always the
ending that the show had i did that
evolve at all or did it always feel like
the most satisfying way to end the
season that was always the ending it was
always the ending was the ending that
was pitched to me like really early on
before we started shooting the show
because of course
i was like i need to know how it ends
because i need to know where i'm going
and um it was so that was always
the ending i mean i think there were
certain machinations in how we got there
that changed but that specific actual
end of the show was always what it was i
can definitely yeah i don't want to
spoil anything but i i can say that you
know
um because i think the audience deserves
to know this that you you she does end
up figuring things out she does end up
filling some holes she does end up
being able to
answer some of the questions that she
has and that the audience has the the
surprise and the twists may be that
what those answers are
and do they
fix everything
this is a good way of putting it
so
how do you find a character i mean it
seems that you know the characters you
play are so fascinating how do you know
when you've found one that you just have
to do i don't know i really don't know
it's an instinctive thing that i can't
put my finger on i think for me i feel
like
an intrinsic connection to the character
that i can't put into words there's
something about her that i know there's
something about her that i understand
and then the
and then the other part of it is just
something that i want to see
like a a show that i want to see a show
that i would want to watch a story that
i would want to watch like that for me
is
i always figure if i want to watch it
there might be a few other people that
do too
and
that's it i approach things as a as an
audience member a lot of the time
well i had a great time watching this i
couldn't wait to see how it all ended so
thank you for talking to me about it
you're welcome thank you good to see you
again
you